all right
you read it for this lecture now all
right let's turn around or do whatever
you want
welcome to another edition of beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike comer
tonight we'll be celebrating the movie
pawn sacrifice it's obviously about
Bobby Fischer and his onslaught of the
Russian Boris Spassky he'll be played by
none other than a Tobey Maguire the best
spider-man ever so so hopefully there'll
be another chest boom and it will be
great so this lecture will go over pawn
sacrifices and I had a big pun sacrifice
on Friday night me and my competitor
were both two and oh and here is the
game I have the black pieces so he
starts out c4 so if they start out c4
you just want to get them out of the
book here with d5 so takes takes Knight
up Queen back so so see if if white is
playing the English they want to play a
very positional game this way you can
get them out of the book and and you
have open lines with the D file here
alright so g3 so he wants to get his
Bishop fianchettoed and castled okay and
we want to break that open so so we're
gonna go for the pawn sacrifice okay and
I knew I was going to teach a lecture
called pawn sacrifice so I really had to
sacrifice a pawn so so the H pawn was
the way to go okay
so so my opponent cleverly sees well if
I just take here rook takes that's not
really a pawn sacrifice so he's like
I'll play check and now I'm attacking
the pawn so I just play silent I don't
want to play a move like this
because then he'll pie Playa Queen to b3
I guess I could Rob that that that still
doesn't even win the pawn I'd have to
take back with the pawn and that would
be very bad for me because what move
would I have to play right now night out
and that would be my pawn sacrifice but
I want to sacrifice the other pond so so
when it gives me a check like this I
just play c6 so now he's got a he's got
a pawn he's up a pawn but but I'm gonna
have open lines to his King so Knight up
that up Knight attacks the Queen Queen
up so I get the other night out
now he gets castle and so you know
attack is Queen again take take Queens
attacked it's going Queen back to g3e
six blocks in my bishop so but I have to
get this Bishop going so b3 not not that
good of a move and in this position
my opponent even though we're both two
and O and all the other games in our
section are irrelevant as a leaning over
and really watching the other game so so
I kindly move my Bishop out and they
cease oh man he played this Bishop
they're free pawn but it's not a pawn
sacrifice what move should black play to
to regain all the material he's lost and
more
and notice my rook is attacked as well
so one we have to guard the rook and
make some some big threats here
yeah Bishop f6 excellent so Bishop
defends the rook through an x-ray and
simultaneously Forks the Queen and the
rook on a1 so Queen back to g3
and see your rook alright so so look
he's trying to box in my bishop which is
good idea what my bishop he's not doing
anything on a1 right so he needs to get
out of enemy territory as fast as
possible okay
so back to huh back to g7 okay what
should black play in this position Queen
f6 right it's same tactic same exact
same tactic yeah don't move your rook
the f8 just Queen f6 offering the trade
obviously we love a deadiy trade because
we're up material so anytime you're up
material and can trade do so bishop
attacks the night did we want to put our
King in a pin no we'll just move our
Knight and attack the bishop obviously
doesn't want to trade any more pieces so
retreats alright
Brooke gets activated so he doesn't want
to be on pin so it just moves out okay
so I gotta get my bishop Oh so rook
attacks the bishop so let's just move it
right okay now it plays Knight to e5 now
we really have to calculate for tactics
here because we're gonna put the knight
in a pin but we don't want to make sure
that he doesn't have any like really
cool moves and luckily he doesn't so so
basically when he plays rook up we can
just take it and now we're just
consolidating the position King up
that's good
Brook attacks the pawn so b5 and now
black has a threat
unfortunately white doesn't see it
notice rooks
are more like vertical pieces than
horizontal pieces so he's kind of
trapped on the on the fourth-ranked
right now
so what move does he have to make right
now to give them any kind of hope to
save this rook because my threat is
obviously a 5d fine right
you just have to throw it away just
throw it away
and now the rook can go but said a four
and a five and the works got no place to
go but it's got a little trick to to at
least not lose a full rook
so rook takes b5 I have to take back
like this and now Bishop takes rook
takes pawn takes Bishop takes and now
it's pretty much over I'm up a rook and
a knight you might have a couple extra
pawns but they're not really doing
anything those are the ones I sacrifice
for or whatever and now Bishop here once
I get this past or it's over so I win
the 36 bucks oh right a game I play in a
house game actually had the black pieces
in this one and luckily I've read the
Smith more gambit fine gold defense
written by Bob Joe phony poker player
and been fine gold blackjack player so I
got a really good really good opening
prep for this one so so Nathan decides
he's gonna be doing the pawn sacrificing
on me so let's see how it goes so I'll
obviously take and then this will go
into how how the fine gold defense has
played usually when they play the Smith
more
black is like oh just play your night at
the c6 that's the last thing we're going
to do in the in the final defense okay
so we just move out or to Center pawns
get our Bishop to protect their queen
he gets castled a6 this is a huge idea
in this defense if I was playing white I
would play a four to prevent b5 but once
I get b5 out now I got my Bishop out
here I can maybe even put my Queen on b7
eventually and I'm doing well
Knight f6 Queen e2 now I should
obviously just get castled or probably
play Bishop b7 instead I think I see a
tactic but I don't
so after b4 Knight goes here so now so
now if I would do Bruce Lee take this
pawn free pawn pawn sacrifice he plays
Bishop to b6 and obviously my queen
would have to move and then my nights
out so luckily I see it and I'm like why
do I play such a stupid but it's alright
so so in this position I have to cut my
losses so I play Knight B to d7 so my
fate you puts anything on b6 I'll take
it with mine eight
so rook up so now I'm like okay I'll
take the pawn and now he gets a really
strange idea here
rook to c6 so Bishop attacks like in the
last lecture we were talking like you
know even if you made a move that's not
so hot you can always just go back so
unfortunately he plays here thinking he
might have something but it doesn't look
like it huh
so rook to c1 so now he's threatening a
lot Rick c7 so what's the easiest way to
combat this rook c8 so takes with check
so Queen takes Knight up prevents me
from checking him alright so I get
castle
Bishop back protects my knight
alright now it attacks the Queen so now
I got I got a good situation going I got
the Queen and Bishop and a battery
aiming at g2 here okay so tied up all
right pawn sacrifice
okay now you got to use these alright so
pawn attacks the bishop so obviously I'm
gonna take it now I have so many ways to
win it's not even funny but I pick the
worst of the worst of the worst
okay so notice if I put my knight
anywhere okay just for grins let's say I
retreat them back here okay
I'm threatening checkmate okay but I
notice that he protects it with Queen
here and now he stopped the checkmate
and guess guess what he's threatening
his own checkmate so
so wait wait what you're richer night
yeah night after is that legal right
so what's funny is as that's actually
the move I play is your your only legal
suggestion so so just for hopefully the
people at home can see the the real move
well it's highlighted on the thing
Knight c3 because when he plays to Queen
to g4 to threaten checkmate I've got
this awesome move Knight check okay and
obviously he plays Queen takes checkmate
but and then King f1 and then I can take
the take the take the bishop okay and
then obviously if it takes it's gonna be
big trouble okay but obviously that's
not even how the game went okay so okay
so in this position I play one of the
worst moves I can play Knight to g3 and
he instantly just takes it and thus
defends the Jeep on simultaneously so I
was very upset about that there's only
one good move in this position Julian
there's only one good move to maintain I
ain't no Bishop f6 yeah of course I
played so when you're mad right like I
obviously I'm mad now because I was plus
9
no it's attacked the bishop so now he
attacks my queen so I decided I'm gonna
attack your queen
so Queen takes bishop takes and now
there's actually one movie has because
look his bishop is under attack and his
Knight is under attack but he has a way
to save them both
yeah Bishop c5 so he makes the threat
greater or equal to his own
so I just take it Bishop takes play rook
up there slam that move slam him as hard
as you can
no no black is better he's got a rook
and he's doing great so I got check
obviously you don't want to go into the
end of the windmill here right yeah yeah
yeah yeah you have even better than to
take the bishop well I would have taken
though I want to take all your stuff
you're in the windmill ain't getting now
all right yeah it's check all right so
King up one so take attacks the bishop
bishop moves take us all there pawn now
we got a passed pawn all right now I
play another funny move so just like in
the first game and I've got to get my
rook stuck but it's got to benefit me
big time
okay I got meeting too and he doesn't
even know it
all right so so rook to h2 what is
White's absolute worst move in this
position
King the t1 is the worst move I guess
what lo and behold he plays it checkmate
and I'm looking pretty good all right
that was my big house game at the ALS
benefit tournament
I can't resist we got to throw throw
this game in just for fun even though it
has nothing to do with pawn sacrifice so
all right so here's a here's the
brothers plane Tamala and Sasha okay get
ready to cover your eyes okay so so
Sasha is the littler brother wait wait
wait I'm thinking it's more like this
all right sorry he could have done a
pawn sacrifice but he's like now I gotta
get my material back so check obviously
c3 is the best but you know Knight up
[ __ ] up attacks the knight so now they
got two guys on it sorry it just takes
the knight now threading a little
checkmate okay g3 queen up so now Queen
droid Queen is threatening checkmate yes
obviously the move in this position was
night to d4 right but didn't see it okay
and now Bishop up and now the little kid
he decides to adjust the f2 or hey just
just and there's like checkmate but
first first he had to really stick it to
his brother
all right
why all right
it is what it is all right so now we got
one more game from the Fred action quad
I had the white pieces against my victim
here all right
so we blitz out all these moves so it's
the French defense nothing really is
going on you can't take my knight on you
for obviously because his knight isn't a
pin by the Bishop h6 Oh Castle just
playing a little good all right so now
he's attack on my knight so protect it
why not take it take it it's great
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes now now
yeah well yeah now obviously Shaq as
everyone can see and I'm doing pretty
well with the check
picking up eight so Knight takes e5 now
obviously he needs to take back the
night instead when he plays here we have
a ninety seven check in between move
here okay
so King e7 and now we can take and
obviously can't take the night his rooks
under attack so now pawn sacrifice he
takes he takes might be too why not you
ready you're down so rook the d1 and
he's not gonna like what happens pretty
soon here so now we have a discovered
attack on the Queen ninety-five moves
the Queen and then Queen f7 is Shaq mate
okay so those are some of my my great
pawn sacrifice game sometimes
you know my opponents doing it to me
sometimes I'm doing it to them but now
the main attraction okay the Bobby
Fischer pawn sacrifice Bobby Fischer see
if he plays as good as I do know this is
unsecure all right yeah I remember that
guy
all right so Bobby Fischer is white and
it's the Rory Lopez and look at how
Bobby Fischer plays the Rory Lopez right
I wasn't bluffing I'm giving you double
pawns deal with it I'm not gonna let you
get a hundred moves chasing my bishop
around the board I'm just gonna take it
and wish grandmasters nowadays would
have the the sense to play like this
now obviously the follow-up is h3 but
Bobby Fischer he's just gonna Castle
right away and and of course his
opponents gonna play the worst move f6
just tempting Bobby Fischer to play
Knight takes e5 but well they're all
whole you're all horrible Bishop g4 is
obviously the best move that's why you
have to play h3 but that's in another
video the worry Lopes so enough said
about that all right
so takes takes Knight up so now Bobby's
just gonna you know develop all his
pieces attack the bishop now do you
think he's gonna take this bishop no
because that would be helping his
opponent out it would straighten out all
his pawns you know so he's like I am not
having any of that so I just move my
cleanup and so gets attacked so he just
takes it Bishop takes attack the bishop
bishop up all right so now he's like
yeah you're never gonna get to move at
all you're gonna be worthless for the
whole game that's why I move five you
had to play Bishop g4
but didn't do all right way to move
forward right move five four or five
whatever everybody have to write after
White Castle well you don't know never
mind never mind alright Bishop attacks
the bishop to take now the bishop gets
out look at look at that great spot for
that patient all right eirick up all
right Queen puts knight and a pen
serious business serious business so he
protects it rook attacks the pawn and
then now what is Bobby Fischer known for
in these positions what's the what's the
move Bobby Fischer plays more than
anybody else in America no in the world
it's well if I still has the record
because nobody else plays this move I
think this is the movie plays it g4
that's right he's like he's going for it
look at all the Bobby Fischer's game
you'll see g4 and there's so much
because he don't care so Queen attacks
the rook Queen protects it rook up all
right this might be time for the pawn
sacrifice obviously like in the other
two games his rook kind of stuck on the
Fah on the rank okay you don't want
rooks on Brinks you want them on files
obviously they have to be on both but
you know what I mean you're better all
right so so pawn sacrifice would play a
knight back now
now the pawn sacrifice freeing up his
rook
so pawn takes now he gets this rook on
the nice efile working with his uh buddy
on the back and things are looking good
so Bishop attacks the rook rook takes it
now he's challenged in the e-file so
takes takes Knight does some
interference here he could try the big
big thing here but but he's got played
better than that he's just gonna play h6
yeah his queen is on d6 currently
because rook takes rook Shak and then
guess what oh my god you just you just
helped my pawns out right obviously 95
all right so they makes dancing around a
little bit and obviously he's never
going to trade the dudes the night for
the bishop because this Knight is so
superior to the bishop so give them a
big check love it Knight g6 he's so in
the territory right now so rook takes
Queen takes and now we have a superior
Knight to this Bishop this Bishop has
been garbage all day so easy enough get
them traded so after Queen takes Knight
takes should be a pretty easy win for
all white and we'll see how he does it
so g5 everybody's in in cahoots right
that told me McGwire was the best
spider-man obviously that Garfield guy
get rid of him get rid of home get rid
of them alright so here we go here we go
here we go all right this is the real
live position Bobby Fischer see how he
closes it out here probably attacks a
pawn right yeah who wouldn't attack a
pawn great job so so look he's attacking
a pawn like if I was playing I'd be like
oh I'm good for your pawn but what am I
really going for if you would play see
six here Knight where hopefully that's
what you've said four four two dudes all
right
so it's always like I see it I see it
and so I was like do I really
once your pawn yeah I wasn't bluffing
that's alright Bishop f3 so he just
attacked our pawn he sees it 98 now
guess what if you take fork again so so
black really should have been like oh my
god I got a LightSquared bishop when
will I get my King on a dark square so I
can't get forked anymore because there's
no way if the King is on a dark square
that can be worked with a light squared
piece but I guess you didn't think about
that
alright so now all right now he's now he
figured it out all right let me get my
King on h6
okay so Knight protects the pawn King
attacks the night so we're gonna be like
all right if you want my knight we'll
take your bishop he's like no sale he's
like fine Knight attacks the pawn always
be attacking so after c4 what move do
you think we should play here and it
might make our opponent resign King g3
and now he's got no hope no hope for
nothing and that's that's all she wrote
right
we're gonna play that and we're going to
fork both your pawns so that's it so
hopefully everybody enjoys a pawn
sacrifice starring Bobby Fischer and let
the boom begin